Paige we're only gonna be talking about
circuits composed of 1 & 2 qubit gates
the depth of such a circuit oops is the
number of layers of gates where within a
layer the gates need to not overlap in
terms of the numbers and we're gonna be
interested in constant depth circuits
okay so what are these constant depth or
shallow circuits good for well we've
known since 2002 that and and you know
much follow-up work in this sort of line
of quantum computational supremacy that
shallow depth quantum circuits can
sample from probability distributions
that if you could sample from them using
an efficient classical computation it
would collapse the polynomial hierarchy
and you know recent work has tried to
make this robust against error we also
know that shallow quantum circuits can
solve certain linear algebra problems
faster than classical algorithms and I
believe that Robin will speak a bit
about this on Friday
I guess one comment is that this in a
sense can be viewed as so when I say
faster I mean faster in terms of circuit
dab and this can be viewed as some kind
of local quantum algorithm that beats
local classical algorithms and so part
of the motivation for this work is just
to understand whether or not these
shallow quantum circuits can be used for
other purposes and whether or not we can
prove or establish you know limitations
of shallow form circuits in these
scenarios so in particular again another
topic that is being mentioned a few
times already has been these variational
quantum algorithms which are sort of
attractive for near-term implementations
because they're very sort of amenable to
be implemented on devices with you know
taking all sorts of different shapes and
forms so the sort of main goal here is
to compute the ground energy of some
Hamiltonian here I'm going to assume
that it's the sum of local terms P I
when I say sorry I misspoke these are
not assumed to be local what I'm going
to assume here is that these P is our
tensor product operators they're a
tensor product of single qubit operator
and we're interested in the minimum
energy and the goal is to compute that
using a quantum computation so like the
only assumption that you need to use
these variational quantum algorithms is
that your quantum device prepares some
subset s of n cubed states and can
measure the energy of some given States
I in that set and then of course you're
going to try to use the quantum device
to minimize the energy over states in
the set s and you will hope that that
approximates the true minimum energy so
I think we've seen this sort of diagram
before you know these variational
quantum algorithms you start with some
knob settings that determine some states
I that your device can prepare you
compute the energy and typically this is
done by focusing first on a single term
so maybe this is a some poly operator
and you measure the all the qubits in
that basis consistent with that poly
operator and compute the expected value
of that poly by repeating this several
times and then you can sum up you know
the answers that you get for the
different value terms to compute an
estimate of the energy and then of
course so if you want to compute the
minimum energy over states and s or
approximate it the strategy that has
been suggested is you start with some
initial knob settings you compute the
energy and then use a classical computer
to to go downhill and you know this is
being suggested and and implemented in
in various ways and you know these
algorithms don't have performance
guarantees although I know that you know
I should say that not all variational
logarithms have performance guarantees
certainly the ones that Eddie was
speaking about I mean he has established
certain performance guarantees but you
know one thing we were interested in is
do these algorithms have an advantage
over classical algorithms and you know
if we can't show in some kind of general
setting that they have an advantage or
we can't establish that then another way
to look at that question is to ask
whether or not we can classically
simulate them and so that was the kind
of approach that we took and you know
one thing to observe is that the quantum
computer here is used only to
approximate expected values at the
output of these shallow quantum circuits
and so we asked what is the complexity
of that task so in particular we have a
shallow quantum circuit you we have a
tensor product observable oh so it's
like oh once in sorrow to up to O N and
we want to know how hard is it to
approximate this mean value on a
classical computer so that you don't
need to run it on a quantum computer
other questions about that okay so this
is the same as what I just said I wrote
out the tensor product here of the
operator oh I am going to assume that
all the terms in the tensor product have
norm spectral norm at most one and
there's sort of an interesting special
case I mean so if I asked you what is
the complexity of computing this
quantity maybe you would first think
about this case so let's take co2 be a
projector on to a computational basis
State well then this mean value is just
the output probability so the
probability of obtaining the bitstream X
after applying the circuit to the all
zero state and we know that computing
out for probabilities of shallow quantum
circuits at least computing very precise
estimates is a very hard problem so that
gives you a little bit of insight and
I'm going to there's two versions of the
mean value problem the one I just sort
of spoke about computing a very precise
estimate I will talk about in a moment
but the first version is what I'll call
the additive error mean value problem
where we're given an inverse polynomial
precision and we want to compute an
estimate that just achieves that
additive error so the difference between
a estimate and the true value in
absolute values at most this inverse
polynomial quantity and you know this
this you could actually do on a quantum
computer right I mean you you run the
circuit you compute the the-the-the you
measure the observable and then you
repeat and accumulate statistics until
you get the error below Epsilon okay on
the other hand the this more precise
type of estimate where we ask for a
relative error so u tilde minus mu is
now that that difference is proportional
to MU so if the mean value itself is
very small you know this is asking for a
much higher precision in
estimate and this problem is Sharpie
hard and so you would not expect to be
able to solve it even on a quantum
computer okay so so I would like to
understand you know the the the
complexity of this problem for constant
depth circuits tensor product
observables and you know what we did is
we studied this for three sort of
special cases we were not really able to
complete characterize the complexity of
this problem for constant depth circuits
but we have sort of three interesting
special cases where this problem becomes
easy for classical computers and so
that's what I'll tell you about in the
rest of the talk
so just for comparison if you was a
polynomial size circuit the observable
is just projected onto a computational
basis state then this precise version as
I mentioned is sharp be hard in the
additive error version I already said it
was can be done efficiently by quantum
computer but in fact it's B could be
complete and now the case where the
circuit is not just a general polynomial
size quantum circuit but instead is a
constant depth circuit
so the first case is a case where the
single qubit observables in the tensor
product are each individually close to
the identity so here we have an
observable and each of the OJS there's a
single qubit observables now they're
very very close to the identity but in a
way that only depends on the depth of
the circuit and not on n okay so this
tensor product
need not be close to the identity okay
just the individual term and in this
part we're going to consider this much
harder type of estimate this relative
error estimate which in the general case
even for constant depth circuits is
sharply hard so you might ask well when
would you ever encounter this sort of
observable right where all the terms in
the tensor product are very close to the
identity so one place you might
encounter it is if you had a noisy
implementation of a shallow quantum
circuit and you so you apply your apply
your shallow quantum circuit to the all
zero state then you apply a noise map
where you just flip each bit with some
probability P and then you measure the
output probability of getting zero okay
so this noisy mean value mu prime it's
straightforward to show that it can be
written as 1 over 2 to the N times noise
free mean value with different single
qubit observables that now depend on the
noise rate P and so this type of noisy
mean value you know can be expressed in
the form that we need for our in the
form that I mentioned in the previous
slide so that in other words these
observables are very close to the
identity in the very high noise regime
so when the noise rate is very close to
1/2 in a way that only depends again on
the circuit depth
ok so what do we prove in this case
where the single qubit observables are
close to the identity we show that there
is a deterministic classical algorithm
which outputs an estimate in U tilde
such that the log of mute ilda is close
to the log of mu
and this you know if we exponentiate
this equation we get so this is an
additive error in the the log which
translates to a relative error in the in
the estimate itself and the running time
of the algorithm for fixed depth D is
polynomial in N in the universe err this
solves this relative error mean value
problem for this restricted set of
observables and the run time can be
improved for geometrically local
circuits for example in two dimension
the algorithm is based on a polynomial
interpolation method which is due to bar
VANOC and which I'll just describe
briefly over the next couple of slides
so we consider a polynomial where you
know previously we had considered a 1/10
sorrow to up to o n but now we're going
to define an an observable Oh J of
epsilon that interpolates between the
identity this should be o sub J and so
now this this expected value of o of
epsilon which is the tensor product of
all of these interpolated observables
that quantity is now a degree n
polynomial in Epsilon and when we take
epsilon to be 0 all of the single qubit
observables are the identity and so this
expected value that the the polynomial
takes the value 1 when epsilon is 0 and
when epsilon is is 1 then all the single
cute observables are the things that we
we want and so then that's the mean
value that we want to compute it's also
true that the derivatives with sort of
low order can be computed efficiently
and so one way to see that is just that
like for example if we take the first
derivative of this polynomial then what
happens is you know we pick up well it
can be expressed in this way as a sum
over J from 1 to N and we have u
conjugating the observable oj- the
identity and because U is a depth D
circuit the support of this operator is
is upper bounded by 2 to the D so this
this quantity can be computed using a
computation
just to to the D qubits which is
constant for constant death
likewise if we have like higher-order
derivatives for example K growing you
know logarithmically with n then we can
compute those derivatives efficiently so
we have a polynomial we know its value
at zero we want to compute its value at
1 we can compute the low order
derivatives so the natural thing to do
is to try to use some kind of Taylor
series expansion but to use barber knock
I mean barber knocks suggestion is a
little bit slightly better than this
because if we use a Taylor series
approximation we'll get some kind of
additive error and what barber knock
says is that we should use the Taylor
series for the log of the function
itself the log of the function rather
than the function itself because at an
additive error in the log translates to
a relative error in the function okay so
you know he says approximate the log by
it's truncated Taylor series so that's
the natural thing to do so we truncate
to order P so here now we're reading GE
for the log of the the polynomial and
what barban ox theorem says is that it
you know you can use this method and you
get a very good approximation to the log
of the polynomial even with a small
value of P like PE growing
logarithmically with n but that in order
to use this you need the polynomial to
be zero free on an on a disk that
contains the region where you want to
interpolate to okay so so there's you
know to use this method you need to be
able to compute these derivatives of the
log of the function and you need to
establish a zero free region for the for
the polynomial and and you know and then
then you get this low degree this is
good approximation
okay so that's what I just said we need
to compute derivatives we know how to
compute the derivatives of F and that
translates and it's very straightforward
to get go from those to the derivatives
of G and so the hard work that we do
here is showing that this polynomial is
zero free as long as the condition on
the observables is met and I'm not
really going to describe that here this
is the theorem that we proved the the
main technical tool here is the lavash
local lemma which somehow you know we
define a probability distribution which
is proportional to the function and then
yeah I mean I have some more slides
about this and if there's time I can I
can get to them or you can ask me about
it later but you know we have this
result which says that these polynomials
that come from shallow quantum circuits
have zero free region that the radius
decreases exponentially in the depth but
does not decrease with em okay and you
could ask you know can this bound on the
zero free radius can be improved so you
could go to you know higher noise rates
or we're sorry lower noise rates and you
can interpolate further and and in fact
you can show from a simple example that
there exists shallow quantum circuits
and sets of observables that that in the
worst case show that this this bound is
very close to optimal so in other words
there's a one of these polynomials which
has a root that indeed is inverse
exponential in the depth of the circuit
however it's also interesting to note
and we show that for random circuits the
zero free radius is typically much
larger and in fact asymptotes to one as
n goes to infinity so that's a major
difference between random circuits and
random shallows or sorry not these are
not shallow circuits here this is these
random circuits have to be drawn from an
ensemble that forms a to design but but
if you have that then this is your free
radius is much larger and we're not sure
what you can do with this observation
but it is kind of curious okay so that's
the first case so when we have constant
depth circuits observables that are
individually close to the identity then
in fact this relative error
your problem can be solved in P and of
course then the additive error one can
too
the next case is a slightly more general
setting so and here we want to consider
you know U is again a shallow quantum
circuit o is now just any for the
purpose of the slide I was just any
tensor product observable where these
are hermitian operators okay and what
this theorem says is that we have a
classical algorithm which estimates the
absolute value of the mean value to
within an additive error Delta and has a
sub exponential scaling within okay so
if so this algorithm unfortunately it
doesn't do exactly what we want because
it estimates the absolute value of the
mean rather than the mean itself so for
example if you wanted to take a shallow
quantum circuit and estimate the
expected value of like poly z tensor n
you could estimate its absolute value
but you would not get the sign
information using this algorithm which
has a sub exponential scaling um but
this does sort of solve this additive
error mean value problem if the
observables are positive semi-definite
in which case the absolute value is just
equal to the value of the mean itself
and and removing this condition that
that you know this fact that we have to
take an absolute value here is kind of
mysterious and I don't know how to get
rid of it okay so how does this work so
again we use some kind of polynomial
method but it's slightly it's it's a
very different polynomial method so
first you know if you're just imagine
for so I'm going to give you a proof
sketch but I want you to just imagine
for a moment that o is unitary okay in
fact it's very easy to reduce to that
case so if I was unitary then this whole
u dagger owe you is itself a shallow
quantum circuit and so we could instead
of estimating this we could estimate its
square and the square of that is just
you know of this form where you here now
is U dagger owe you from before okay so
now we want to estimate like the output
probability of getting zero after
applying a shallow quantum circuit to
the all zero state
and to do that you can use a method
which has previously been used by Harrow
and Eldar and also has come up in other
places where we define a local
Hamiltonian which is you know the sum of
the predictors onto the the one of qubit
J conjugated by the unitary u this
Hamiltonian has the property that the
state that we care about that we want to
you know this is the output of the
shallow circuit is the zero energy
grounds the unique zero energy ground
state of this Hamiltonian and then our
goal is going to be to construct a low
order polynomial function of this
Hamiltonian that approximates the
projector on to this state and this can
be done using polynomials that come from
query complexity in fact you could use
just a shifted and rescale chebyshev
polynomial but this polynomial from
query complexity does a little bit
better in the in the dependence on the
air okay so we get this polynomial
function of this Hamiltonian which is
sort of low degree like low meaning sub
linear and N and then and then the
desired approximation is just to take
the expected value of that polynomial
function of the Hamiltonian sandwich
between all zeros and an exact
computation of this quantity can be done
in sub-exponential runtime using the
fact that the polynomial degree is
sub-exponential and M okay so that's
kind of the sketch of that algorithm and
so for the case of constant depth
circuits where the observables are
positive semi-definite well again i
didn't say this but the the relative
error problem is again sharp be hard but
the additive error problem we show is a
solvable in sub-exponential classical
time we would really like to replace
this with hermitian and not have the
positive semi-definite restriction but
as i said i don't know how to do that
okay so the last thing and if you
so now this case may be the most
practical practical II interesting so
what I'm going to say here does not rely
on anything I said before and may be of
interest to people that are interested
in two-dimensional geometries so now if
we have a cube it's located at the
vertices of a two-dimensional grid and
again we consider a shallow quantum
circuit where the gates act between
nearest neighbors on the grid then what
we can show is that there's a randomized
classical algorithm which solves the
additive error mean value problem so it
outputs an estimate to within some given
additive error and the runtime of the
algorithm is linear in n for constant
depth but it has a very bad pre factor
of 2 to the O of d squared ok so if you
could improve this pre factor this
algorithm could really be practical I
mean as I said for constant depth it is
a linear time algorithm but you know if
depth if the depth here is for example 7
or 8 you're sort of in big trouble
because of this pre factor okay right so
linear time
the well it is so the the algorithm is
based on a matrix product state
representation and Monte Carlo method
I'm I'm going to sketch it in the last
couple of minutes and then we can go to
the break okay so here's the expected
value you is this 2d geometrically local
circuit these are the general hermitian
observables and so now we're just going
to redefine we want to just write this
as an amplitude of a quantum circuit so
we're just going to redefine we're going
to define sorry Q sub J to be the U
dagger oju so this is a now a gate I'm
viewing this as a gate and the Q the Q J
is all commute with one another okay and
moreover because U is a 2d geometrically
local circuit it expands the support of
the single qubit operator o J only in
its sort of light cone so you can trace
it back through the circuit apply this
one layer gates at a time and you will
see that the support of this Q sub J
operator is only in a 2 D by 2 D square
region centered at qubit J now we have a
quantum circuit composed of these gates
that are only supported on these 2 D by
2 D regions and what we're going to do
as a first step is we're going to
coarse-grain the qubits into these super
sites of size 2 D by 2 D and the reason
for doing that is so that each one of
these gates only acts between a placket
of four of the super sites okay so this
gate now now that I've coarse-grained my
qubits into these super sites it only
acts on these four of them and you know
the ones that are out here that I didn't
picture it just doesn't touch okay so
here's my 2d lattice and here I of
course grained into these super sites
and this is the amplitude that I wish to
compute and each of these gates commutes
with the other ones and acts only on a
plaque hat and now what am I going to do
I would like to reexpress this as an
inner product between two states by even
and Phi on so Phi odd is you know the
zero state
with all of the gates on the plackets
that i've shown here so they're the
gates that act on the between the the
odd columns so here column one and
column three by even consists of all the
gates that act on the even columns so
here just column two and the reason that
I can separate out the even from the odd
columns is because all of the gates
commute with one another so now I have
an inner product between these two
states corresponding to you know this by
odd you can see is a actually a tensor
product of a state that lives on these
two columns of super sites in these two
columns of super sites and in fact the
state here which is tensor product with
state here both of those are matrix
product states just because it has this
1d geometry
likewise Phi even is a matrix product of
matrix product states with a different
ordering so for a matrix product state
you have to choose an ordering of the of
the cutit and here we're choosing a
different ordering and so now we use the
fact that the inner product between
matrix product states can be estimated
using a Monte Carlo method and actually
this Monte Carlo method is more general
it says that if you have to state two
states and you want to compute their
inner product up to a given additive
error then you can always do that as
long as the states have the following
property you need to be able to
efficiently sample from the output you
know if you were to measure the state
then you should be able to classically
sample from that distribution and you
should be able to give an X compute the
amplitude on X and so here because each
of these are you know tensor products of
matrix product States and because matrix
product states have that feature we can
just use this general fact that you know
inner products can be estimated for
pairs of states that have that feature
okay so this is the last thing I wanted
to say which is that when you have a 2d
constant depth circuit and hermitian
tensor products observables then we know
how to estimate mean values in bgp and
so you know you could say well does this
have any bearing on the
performance of variational quantum
algorithms with two-dimensional circuits
and I would say that you know maybe yes
and maybe no and the reason maybe no is
because the scaling with the depth is
very poor and so I think that you know
it's still possible that you could you
know significantly beat what can be done
on the classical computer even at low
depth because of this too to the oh of
d-squared prefactor ok so what are some
open problems you know maybe you notice
that we didn't really solve the big
question which is you know what is the
complexity of this additive error mean
value problem for constant depth
circuits so if you have a shallow
quantum circuit and you want to compute
the expected value say of just Z tensor
n at the output how hard is that problem
and we still don't know the answer and
there's some other questions that I'll
leave you with
[Applause]
I would like to within some give an
error in the total variation distance no
no it's just
it lets you that algorithm will let you
compute as I said an inner product to
some additive error where both of the
states and the inner product can sort of
be classically simulated in that sense
but those are just samples so it's like
you have a you know this represents an
amplitude of a quantum circuit and
you're taking some of the gates and
shoving them into this state the other
ones and shoving them into this state
but if you wanted to sample from the
full thing then then we don't know how
to do it and and Sayeed marivan who I
think is here yeah
well I think it's just a sort of
versatile technique and I don't know
that there's a formal relationship
between the two no I think it's just two
uses of the same method
yes
second row and the third row well here
the these observables have to be close
to the identity but these ones are just
general positive semi-definite
possibly Prez between the hermitian
operator and was the subject name in the
additive error case because you can
always decompose it to life oh but this
is the individual operators in the
tensor product so a tensor product of
hermitian operators you shift by a
constant times the identity is no longer
a tensor product it's not a tensor
product or the positive semi-definite
operator
and how long is it this one probably my
father was
No so if I understand correctly I think
what you're suggesting is you know you'd
say well if you take a hermitian
operator you can just shift it by a
constant times the identity and make it
a positive semi-definite operator but
this algorithm requires that the
operator be a tensor products like a 1
1002 up to o n so if I take like for
example Z tensor n that's from Missha
so now let's say I shift it so I take
identity plus C tensor n that's now
positive semi-definite but it's not a
tensor product
okay so let's think game it again
[Applause]